bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports le second épisode de
cette saison sur tv 78 l'émission est
toujours consacrée à l'actualité
sportive locale et nos chroniqueurs sont
avec nous pour décortiquer et analyser
cette actualité
vu les conditions sanitaires certains
sont en plateau et d'autres via écran
interposé présentation de cette équipe
de rêve
on commence à ma gauche il est de retour
dans cette émission est devenu petit à
petit un pilier de ce talk les fans du
club de football de saint-etienne il
adore ou les sports il fait notamment du
basket et du handball fauteuil stéphane
de visée est avec lui en plateau rugby
fauteuil jean mary j ça aurait un même
mot savin la pêche content de revenir
ici avec plus d'envié plus l'envi de
contrarier mes collègues
et puis voilà oui ça fait un petit
moment que vous n'avez pas lu ici
non non non bien le confinement les
soucis du educooo vide et puis vous êtes
de retour en tout cas voilà je suis là
pour bien embêter tout le moins en passe
de l'autre côté musique lui aussi est
avec nous en plateau c'est sa seconde
apparition dans cette émission et les
journalistes chez tb 78 les passionnés
de culture italienne et de score il
colle et où surtout il a sa rubrique
dans cette émission à chaque
enregistrement le journaliste de tv
60,18 le l'italian lovers baigorri
canale est avec nous bonjour michel
bonjour comment allez vous ça va très
bien content bas comme la dernière fois
d'avoir rejoint cette immersion par les
sports est content de continuer avec
vous de partager cette passion du sport
vous êtes prêts on est aujourd'hui vers
faut être toujours prêt pour reparler de
sport alors nous serons donc 3 en
plateau et les autres sont avec nous via
écran interposé à cause du contexte
sanitaire comme je l'expliquais c'est
notre spécialiste cyclisme mais il s'y
connaît dans tous les sports ce sportif
en roue libre et licencié au club 2
vélizy et il vient tout juste de
s'inscrire au volley ball le capitaine
yann dujarrier et bien sûr tournée est
avec nous également via écran interposé
bonsoir michael bonsoir
grégory mon cher stéphane comment
allez-vous soir super bien super bien
c'est vrai que le confinement est
terminé mais on est encore à l'île de
man est encore exactement pas non plus
pas encore tous se retrouver et vivre
normalement je vous cache pas que cela
commence à me courir sur le haricot pour
rester polie mais mais tout va bien
grosse satisfaction c'est vrai que
dernièrement on a eu le tour de france
qui nous permet qu'il a permis de passer
un peu de temps on a enchaîné avec
roland garros et en même temps on a un
tour d'italie
donc les journées sont bien alors lui
aussi connecté via écran interposé c'est
une légende de cette émission un
combattant il n'hésite pas à lancer des
débats
vous allez passer un excellent moment
avec lui j'en suis sûr le gladiateur
pierre chevallier est avec nous pierre
chevallier quand allez vous vous formez
bonheur à tous ça va très bien très bien
ravi de retrouver quinze jours plus tard
des petits camarades
même à distance je crois qu'il va se de
tout seul son falloir s'habituer ce
petit contexte un petit peu courant sur
le haricot canzian un petit décor
champêtre inde à la voix voilà c'est
prêt s'est massé m'allonger r normandes
alors en garde la meilleure pour la fin
elle est une titulaire indiscutable de
cette émission son sourire est ravissant
cea nelly sont renversantes
hélène de la grange spécialiste pole
dance à versailles est avec nous
normalement à voilà on la voit hélène
comment allez vous nous avons un petit
coin de technique on ne vous entend pas
la dernière
d'accord et vous êtes là du coup voilà
vous entend et l'est mais on est content
de vous avoir en tout cas alors avant de
passer au programme 2 avant de passer au
programme de l'émission prend maintenant
la direction de saint-germain-en-laye
une première mondiale s'est déroulée à
dans la ville le trailer fabrice
pancrate qui a réalisé sur trois jours
une course de 45 heures sur un tapis
roulant
à l'occasion de la virade des rois un
événement pour vaincre la mucoviscidose
au total ce spécialiste des longues
ce a parcouru 160 kilomètres avec 10000
mètres de dénivelé on écoute justement
l'ultra trail heures au micro de justin
brasier je vous avoue je suis totalement
épuisé j'ai dormi une heure la nuit
dernière la avant-hier et 2h cette nuit
et je dormais dans ma voiture qui est
juste en face donc je suis totalement
épuisé et puis il ya l'effort physique
qui est extrêmement difficile puisque
sur un tapis on fait toujours le même
geste
ça veut donc dire que ce sont toujours
les mêmes muscles qu'il travaille et je
suis pétri de tendinites
donc en plus il a fallu gérer la
souffrance liée à la douleur de ses
tendinites
quel est votre avis sur cette
performance
je pense des ferries c'est exceptionnel
mais bon c'est déjà un grand champion
j'ai vu un peu son wikipédia j'ai vu
qu'il participe à beaucoup de course
paris versailles et les marathons
finalement connu que je crois qu'il a
fait aussi chez lui pendant le
confinement
163 kilomètres déjà repeint en ville et
déjà affûté
si c'est pour une bonne cause il faut
parler de la mucoviscidose c'est
vraiment une saloperie cette maladie
faut sensibiliser sensibiliser les gens
partent donc et c'est vraiment quelque
chose de fabuleux qu'il a fait je dis
bravo
je suis d'accord avec stéphane sur le
côté sensibiliser c'est bien qu'il ait
pu parler de cette maladie qui tue
beaucoup de personnes en france qui
touche 6500 personnes en france
il ya des gens connus comme grégory
lemarchal qui est mort à 23 ans est si
important de savoir c'est que
l'espérance de vie aujourd'hui étaient
quarante ans pour la mucoviscidose elle
été que de 5 ans dans les années 60
c'est à dire qu'avec de l'argent avec la
recherche ça peut progresser la
librairie c'est donc c'est bien qu'ils
aient aussi
voilà des grands champions comme comme
comme ce triathlète cet ultra trailer
qui qui arrive à faire de telles
performances vient du guerrier je trouve
dommage qu'il faille se mettre dans un
état physique aussi difficile pour
pouvoir faire parler d'une maladie qui
est aussi aussi grave qu'elle puisse
être et et on dont on ne guérit pas mais
mais dont on
les progrès de la médecine permettent
simplement de vivre avec
voilà je j'ai toujours beaucoup de mal
avec enfin j'aurais vraiment préféré
qu'il fasse ce type d'effort sur une
piste et courir pendant pendant tout
premier rang de la courir sur un tapis
psychologiquement pour moi c'est s'aider
des heures et des heures de souffrance
simplement parce que parce que ben ouais
c'est c'est l'image du hamster qui est
dans sa roue et qui va qui va tourner
avec il a tourné en rond pour cent
c'était une première mondiale un
nigérien je le rappelle comment c'était
une première mondiale
et j entends ma vie avec un décalage
c'était une première mondiale cette
performance oui oui bien sûr oui mais ça
n'empêche que je trouve alaia il ya un
moment où en effet comme il le dit
physiquement il est détruit
et en plus il a fait quasiment tout au
moral
donc oui bien sûr que c'est un record
mondial je trouve juste dommage d'être
obligé pour une maladie qui est
aujourd'hui très connu et d'être obligé
de faire des efforts aussi important et
de et de se faire aussi mal physiquement
pour pouvoir aider des êtres maladie et
donc du coup du coup et c'est juste ça
que je trouve dommage ni plus ni moins
pierre chevallier
je vais bien mais si t'as pas il ya
dujarrier s'était levé la main je serai
pas je serai pas aussi n'ont pas aussi
forcément trancher parce que même si
c'est des conditions particulières n'est
pas forcément pas forcément celle qu'on
a l'habitude de voir dans le sport je
trouve que le sport est bon pour la
santé il est bon pour les causes c'est à
dire des cons et qu'on a la possibilité
de te tirer la lumière sur sur un
exploit sportif
en l'occurrence ce lieu celui ci certes
particulier sur un tapis en intérieur
mais
dans tous les cas ça nous ça nous fait
en parler sur votre éminent plateau donc
donc si c'est une bonne chose après on
parle souvent d'exploit en tout genre et
d'exploits originaux on en a parlé la
dernière fois sur la traversée de la
france
roller ou d'un désert de sel de notre
ami de notre ami vie moi là en
l'occurrence et c'est une bonne chose
dans un contexte particulier qui qui
érode un petit peu les tués étaient
sportif de pouvoir parler des bonnes
choses et de récolter des fonds pour les
8-12 c'est pas mal hélène de la grange
votre avis sur cette performance les
deux c'est sûr que des performances qui
ont lieu en extérieur le contexte c'est
quand même plus et plus agréable et
voilà c'est un autre message
maintenant tous les moyens sont bons
pour quand elle continuer à avancer sur
certaines causes a régné et du monde
certaines causes quand même permis la
visibilité que les rythmes monde était
[Musique]
un petit peu de mal à vous entendez
laine si vous pouvez éventuellement
bouger un petit peu chez vous je sais
pas si c'est possible oui c'est pour
récupérer a juste après en tout cas au
total l'ultra trail de fabrice a permis
de récolter plus de 9000 euros vous
pouvez continuer à faire vos dons à
l'association encore pendant un mois par
téléphone au 0 800 100 à 500 nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du tournoi de tennis de roland
garros des yvelinois ont participé au
rendez vous porte d'auteuil cette année
coup de projecteur également sur livin
waha tony yoka qui a gagné son combat de
boxe en 87 secondes
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler jo de 2024
j aux deux gigots de 2024 la fédération
française de cyclisme l'a confirmé la
colline d'elancourt va bien accueillir
les épreuves de vtt lors des jeux
parisiens un temps remis en question le
site a été confirmée dans le dossier les
courses de bmx ont également été
confirmés dans l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines tout comme les
épreuves d'équitation à versailles un
temps envisagée à lamotte beuvron les
yvelines vont également organiser le
cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome
nationale le golf au golf national
on écoute la réaction de laurent basauri
vice président délégué aux sports sur la
confirmation des sites à saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est une excellente nouvelle ville est
vrai que nous avions eu un peu peur mais
un tout petit peu peur parce qu'il nous
semblait absolument logique que nos
sites soit confirmée le seul sur lequel
planait encore un léger doute
c'était celui de la colline d'elancourt
pour les épreuves de vtt et bien c'est
chose faite cette semaine tout a été
plutôt la semaine dernière tout a été
confirmé
la logique est respectée c'était le plus
beau site le site le plus adapté le site
le plus près de paris est aussi un c'est
pas neutre mais le site le plus
écologique donc c'est ce site qui est
retenu nous aurons donc bien à 50 ans en
et v4 cité six épreuves le département
pourrait également recevoir une partie
des épreuves de cyclisme sur route la
validation définitive de tous ses sites
devrait intervenir d'ici la fin de
l'année
grégory rapidement la colline
d'elancourt c'est quoi alors amplement
déjà ce qu'il faut dire c'est que ce
dossier du site de la colline
d'elancourt n'est pas nouveau à l'instar
du vélodrome nationale ce site était
déjà prévu dans le dossier de
candidature aux jo de 2012 qui ont été
finalement attribués à londres alors
cette colline d'elancourt c'est le point
culminant d'île de france 231 m on peut
y voir de cette colline du sommet de
cette colline la tour eiffel par exemple
c'est le site d'une ancienne carrière où
on n'a plus pu mettre des terres des
gravats qui ont été amoncelés lors de la
construction de la ville nouvelle de
saint quentin en yvelines dans les
années 70 alors depuis la nature a
repris ses droits des compétitions
sportives
s'ils tiennent à la verdure note avoir
tout à fait y alla revancharde qui se
tient chaque année
sur cette colline qu'une compétition de
vtt il ya les championnats de france
fsgt qui s'y sont tenus également en
2007 cet incident en 2016
un site que l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines souhaite valoriser
qu'elle souhaite donner un avenir avec
des aménagements vu de ces géo alors le
site a pu être remis en question pour
son impact environnemental
un autre point soulevé michael c'est
aussi celui du dénivelé qui ne
rendraient pas le parcours aussi
compétitif c'est pourquoi le championnat
dans les épreuves ont été un temps
évoqué du côté de chamonix on a pu aussi
parler de ces épreuves de vtt en effet
de chamonix dans les alpes mais la
colline d'elancourt a tenu la corde elle
devrait être sauf grande surprise pour
ces jo le site de ceux de ces épreuves
je vais y arriver de vtt vielle de
jarrier c'est banaliser ou par
intervenir sont toujours souvent la
décision du 17 décembre dans l'accord
final
cette fois ci on n'est pas encore sûr et
certain car ils ne savent pas encore si
oui ou non le vtt sera inscrit au jo de
- son lancement c'est pas du sens et
n'est pas sûre à 100% le site a été
retenu mais les preuves ne sera pas
forcément organisé voilà il ya dujarrier
vous qui êtes notre spécialiste cyclisme
est ce que vous comprenez ou pas cette
décision de maintenir la colline de
l'encours mais complètement je me
souviens du parcours du sur les lieux
blonde qui était aussi un parcours
complètement
c'était pas un parcours naturel c'était
un parcours qui avait vraiment fabriquer
pour course 7 est pas donc du coup la
commune d'hallencourt est une colline
qui est existante
il y aura des aménagements à faire pour
peut-être un petit peu durcir le durcir
le parcours et augmenter un peu de
dénivelé mais mais il a tout à fait sa
place est plus voilà tout dire on reste
à un ouais une demi heure de paris quand
on est quand on est sur l emploi en
voiture pour moi c'est normal que ce
type de sites puissent le recevoir c'est
et ces épreuves est d'ailleurs assez
bien que toutes les épreuves de cyclisme
puisse avoir lieu dont 78 vraiment
pouvoir emmagasiner emmagasiné l'aclu et
tant mieux
voilà on a le vélodrome originale de la
piste de bmx qui va être qui est mature
sur la base de loisirs l'épreuve de
route normalement est prévue en vallée
de chevreuse vous n'avez pas parlé je
sais pas si ce n'est pas en q3 pour le
cyclisme sur route normalement ça
devrait être un départ vers rambouillet
pour une arrivée sur les champs elysées
mais ce n'est pas encore confirmé en
d'accord voilà du bon ça ça reste en
ratant 218 et donc les yvelines et sera
sont remises à
à l'honneur donc longtemps très très
bien et moi c'est ça me remplit de
bonheur puisque j'ai envie de pouvoir
participer pas participer les pouvoirs
voir un maximum d'épreuves quand quand
les jo seront prochainement 2024 voilà
pierre chevalier qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de cette colline d'elancourt moi
je trouve que je trouve qu'il faut se
rappeler que c'est paris de 1024 x et
djo à paris on a souvent on a souvent
délocaliser un certain nombre d'épreuves
ou par nécessité ou pas au parent ou par
obligation
la plupart du temps jeu notamment les
épreuves de voile vont être organisées
du côté de marseille et ça fait ça fait
on va dire ça met un coup de projecteur
et sarens a fait bosser les
territorialités un peu partout en france
mais ça reste une organisation
parisienne ccc les jo de paris 2024 donc
si on peut trouver un lieu qui est
proche de paris comme les cocktails en
cours ça me semble cohérent dans la
tenue du dossier et l'organisation
surtout et la logistique
parce qu'il faut une fois et être aussi
à proximité du village olympique pour
les athlètes
si cette épreuve si c'était preuve est
confirmée donc je trouve ça à la fois
cohérent bien pour les yvelines parce
que on le rappelle souvent ici c'est une
terre de sport donc dans le cadre des
jus des jo de paris
ça me semble une bonne chose de l'avoir
à -2 à -2 32 30 ou 40 km et paraît chez
xavi même signalement la ville et même
si les panoramas sont superbes
hélène je crois qu'on vous a récupéré ça
va mieux je me suis reconnecter ça
devrait était celui-là donc voilà on
attend de savoir si c'est validé moi je
pense que c'est validé aux français mais
après il faut que ça passe par là cio
qui validera ensuite voilà qu'on est la
validation vraiment toutes les instances
mais on attendait avec impatience à voir
cette réponse là on sait que le lieu est
complètement
il est complètement possible de
l'aménager et d'en profiter on reste en
région parisienne comme l'on dit yann et
pierre donc pourquoi pas et pourquoi
aller chercher plus loin et ailleurs
alors que tout est par ici et que c'est
complètement possible on parle pas en
plus d'un réaménagement total du site
pour créer de toute pièce quelque chose
on est déjà une bonne base pour pouvoir
faire les preuves ces épreuves-là donc
pour moi si ça peut se faire ici
voilà on aimerait on attend cette
réponse mais j'aimerais bien que ce soit
validé aussi
donc si je comprends bien c'est un grand
oui autour de cette table et via écran
interposé pour pour la colline
d'elancourt est-ce que vous validez
également les autres sites grégory par
exemple le golf national juste quelque
chose à rajouter c'est vrai que j'ai je
suis d'accord avec ce qui a été dit sur
les infrastructures existantes c'est
voilà on les a dans les yvelines donc il
faut aussi en profiter on pourra parler
du vélodrome nationale ou du golf
national dans un instant moi la seule
interrogation sur la colline à l'instar
de ce qui a pu se passer dans d'autres
gillot c'est moi ma volonté c'est de
voir quand même un projet durable qu'ils
puissent après durée dans le temps et
qui puisse servir aussi à l'avenir ce
qu'on a vu des infrastructures qu'ont pu
être construite pour les jo qui
aujourd'hui sont à l'abandon a des
choses à tokyo dans le monde entier
donc la rio tout à fait donc moi 100%
pour la colline d'elancourt mais avec un
projet durable qui les voilà qui va
pouvoir donner un avenir à cette colline
d'elancourt normalement c'est sur les
rails également pour un projet un peu
plus durable le golf national c'est
logique pierre chevallier vous qui est
le nôtre spécialistes golf a redit aussi
des golfs aussi battu d'abord évidemment
c'est logique on a un site qui a été qui
a été de nombreuses fois plébiscité au
niveau national et international des
open de france depuis depuis de
nombreuses années la ryder cup avec le
succès que l'on connaît en 2018
donc évidemment ce parcours de
championnat qui s'installe
définitivement à nos portes et dans
notre département des yvelines c'est
c'est le lieu évidemment le lieu dédié
pour pour une très très belle
compétition olympiques de hull golf
l'assuré qui a d'ailleurs fêté ses 30
ans
chevallier c'était le lundi 5 octobre
j'ai vu j'ai vu un petit un petit mot du
président de la fédération française de
l'époque claude roger quartier qui
effectivement rappelé que qu'en 1990 ce
parcours sortait de terre de manière
assez anonyme
dessiné par hubert chesneau à l'époque
et puis au fur et à mesure des années il
ya eu déjà eu des investissements il ya
eu des gros objectif est d une belle
stratégie à la fois sportive et
spectacle qui en a fait le bijou de vie
joue gauche x et c'est aujourd'hui le
vélodrome nationale il ya du jarrier on
valide également
bah oui parce qu'il faut bien remplir ce
rôle mais comment ces bains des beaux
événements comme ceux de comme ce que
matthew nationale se rappelant de
rappeler à tous les jours pour aller en
queue pour aller applaudir nos sportifs
français
donc tu à rester aussi un très bel outil
un tous les sportifs qui qui ont pu
venir tous les partis internationaux ont
pu venir rouler sur ce sur ce vélodrome
tous l'ont tous dit que c'était une très
bonne piste elle doit elle doit avoir
toute façon seul bleu drôme que l'on est
très mauvais rhume que l'aude et en
france qui pour n'accueillir libéraux
vélodrome 1 et pour une fois il y aura
du vélo au vélodrome oui pour le foie
gras du vélo on est bien d'accord c'est
bien sûr c'est heureusement ils n'ont
pas le moteur en jeu merci non c'est
très bien comme ça et et on va on est
comme vous dirais que tous les sportifs
ou toujours dit que se dérouleront 8 et
très doux et donc pourquoi il a le
devoir et aura l'honneur de pouvoir
porter ensuite le
les drômois outil formidable il est beau
ce vélodrome le championnat de dhe
pompiers quand les pompiers de toute la
france s'étaient affrontés ouvrit
laudrin y avait même eu les pompiers de
new york
c'était ça n'est pas du cyclisme là
c'est là sur le col y aura d'ici quand
il sourit tout ça c'est la seule fois où
j'y suis allé il est fantastique c'est
derrière questions sur le dernier site
yvelinois c'est l'équitation château de
versailles pareil hélène forcément un
château de versailles ça sonne comme une
évidence
en sachant que la fédération
d'équitation vous voulez le déplacer sur
un petit peu leur clairefontaine de
l'équitation
ce ne sera pas le cas alors on aime on
aime penser voilà on aime quand les
manifestations de se passe chez nous
qu'on a les impressions ou comment on
peut accueillir et mettre en place qu'il
faut après je pense que le choix tout en
restant lokad doit aussi prendre en
compte un peu la meilleure
infrastructure pour pouvoir accueillir
ça donc là je sais pas la structure
concernant l'équitation si on peut
vraiment accueillir toutes les activités
autour d'équitation ou voilà je connais
pas assez c'est comment dire que ce lieu
là pour pour avoir un avis sur la
question tranche p2 est ce que c'est
mieux que ce soit ici ou ailleurs
justement de gros risques pour nous
éclairer sur ce site alors cessé au
château de versailles aura ce panorama
du château de versailles
moi je rejoins ce qui a été dit en tout
cas sûre sur le côté local
c'est important on parle de gio de paris
après pour moi paris ne va pas sans la
région ile-de-france donc c'était tout à
fait aussi logique que les jo se
déroulent partout en ile-de-france et le
château de versailles je trouve que
c'est une belle vitrine en tout cas pour
ceux comment dire cette discipline que
qu'elle l'équitation il ya aussi les
écuries royales 1 au château de
versailles il faut pas oublier donc non
le site du château de versailles ne
semble tout à fait justifié en tout cas
le céou validera ou non ces sites en
décembre prochain on continue cette page
coup de projecteur part du tennis
arthur rinderknecht a disputé cette
année pour la première fois cette année
roland garros en simple le joueur
originaire de 25 ans formé à saint
germain en laye au comité des yvelines
de feucherolles aujourd'hui 163e joueur
mondial s'est incliné au premier tour
face au slovène aljaz bedene et 25 ans
tu sixième joueur mondial
arthur et maintenait sa quand même
réussi à lui prendre un set le score 6 2
6 7 6 4 6 4
on écoute la réaction de l'un des hommes
qui l'a vu grandir dans les mines
patrick ottawa où il était invité sur
l'autre plateau on l'a tourné à steam
aulas la seule inconnue qu'on avait
c'était premier roland garros
peut-être un peu de fébrilité table il a
fait les qualifs l'année dernière il a
fait un excellent match par rapport aux
conditions de jeu par rapport à un
joueur qui est un peu plus fort que lui
il arrive à lui prendre un set qui rate
un petit peu le coche au troisième il a
une petite occases mais là il n'y a pas
beaucoup de place mais n'ont très
satisfaisant super comportement super
attitude on est fiers de lui ce n'est
pas de souci une réaction sur arthur
wint nash peut-être ses fans devise est
je connais pas assez bien je sais qu'il
a été invité que qui s'est bien
débrouillé pour une première fois que je
crois que j'étais encore en compet en
double il à faire double vous pouvez
faire double également arrêté un ami
mais également au deuxième tour il est
mignon deuxième tour
ça va le forger une expérience et puis
voilà et les sur le circuit depuis
environ trois ans donc il apprend il
apprend régression sur le circuit depuis
trois ans il a 25 ans il est 163e joueur
mondial a cette année 2020 c'est
peut-être un petit peu son année aussi
donc première première participation en
simple un tournoi du grand chelem que
roland-garros parce qu'on avait déjà
nation où là il ya deux ans tout à fait
avec
florian la carte est également yvelinois
est également hesdinois également formé
à fâches roll aussi dans ce pôle du
tennis à feucherolles d'ici dans les
yvelines
donc voilà c'est une belle progression
il a gagné cette année deux tournois
challengers y revient de quatre ans où
il a été formé au texas dans une
université il a pu notamment gagné sur
la volée qui est un petit peu une
spécificité américaine au tennis donc
non en belle progression et c'est aussi
encourageant pour la suite
à 25 ans de disputer ce premier tournoi
du grand chelem et du guerrier
arthur glen loch ness escaut connaissiez
pas du tout pas du tout mais il aurait
dû le faire plus que ce gaston qui est
allée jusqu'aux 8es de finale donc c'est
gaston c'est la nouvelle génération lui
a un petit plus l'attaquant de trois
entrées bigouin jeudi jugent que alors
après je dis n'a franchement je n'ai pas
et je regarde les tels étaient les
primes qui était versée aux joueurs qui
perdait un premier tour donc je ne sais
pas si c'est les mêmes pour les joueurs
invités ou pas mais si c'est le cas tant
mieux pour eux parce que je pense que ça
peut donner un peu de tranquillité
financière pour pour une ou deux saisons
longtemps pris l'eau qui reversait après
le premier 3 donc c'est très bien que tu
as puisse mettre quelques quelques
français à l'honneur et puis après de
toute façon ça les fait aussi grandir à
l'ordre cette année c'est vrai que
c'était quand même très très particulier
avec cette jauge admis le spectateur sur
surtout le soul stades d'europe
du coup on ne retrouve pas de l'ambiance
l'ambiance habituelle d'un tournoi du
grand chelem
un peu les livres tous les ans et donc
je ne suis pas sûr que en termes de en
terme d'expérience et gestion de ses
émotions de des émotions dans le match
ça leur apporte grande beaucoup de
choses mais par contre que j'ai
rencontré des adversaires de cette de ce
calibre puisque là ils m'ont même string
et apparemment ils qui aurait pu être
prenable
voilà c'est quand même toujours
intéressant de pouvoir se mesurer à des
adversaires d'un niveau des niveaux
supérieurs aux dépôts
et pour info pour préciser ce que vous
disiez sur la jauge à roland garros sa
famille n'a pas pu participer
enfin le voit sur ce roland garros pour
son premier roland garros car ils n'ont
pas eu d'accréditation forcément à cause
de la joueuse qui a été réduite
bien sûr c'était une grande frustration
ils ont dû le regarder à la télévision
comme tout le monde
pierre chevalier une petite réaction sur
arthur rinderknecht c'est là aussi où je
rejoins jean les petits camarades sur le
sur la tenue de l'événement et dans des
conditions extrêmement particulières
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils ce qu'il ait
pas qu'il est vraiment en pâtit
sportivement et des conditions alors que
sa famille n'ait pas pu assister au
match ça fait un entretien - mais en
tout cas c'est bien c'est bien de voir
ces petits jeunes qui selon ce qui se
lancent dans l'aventuré il ya été tué un
petit peu plus de d'ouverture sur le sur
le tableau sur cette option sur cette
édition un petit peu modifié finalement
la seule sur deux passes à sa prestation
hmm hmm hmm et courtrai était un petit
peu justement occultée par le parler
très belle prestation de gaston sur le
public c'est vrai que pour le coup à
roland garros et en français et jouant
face un slovène il aurait pu bénéficier
peut-être de l'appui du public
on sait sur le scénario du match il
prend le deuxième set aux slovènes
et dans le troisième il a quelques
possibilités c'est peut-être là le
tournant du match où il peut il peut
revenir durablement et peut-être
s'imposer dans dans ce match alors après
le slovène 3 qui les 50e 60e mondiale
quand ils 56e mondiale mais peut-être
que l'appuyer l'a perdu en huitièmes de
finale d'ailleurs et il a perdu en
huitièmes de finale mais peut-être que
l'appui du public aurait pu être un plus
dans ce match avec un roland garros bien
plein je pense que ce serait pas été le
même résultat il aura peut-être
l'occasion de revenir l'année prochaine
lors d'une session peut-être où il y
aura du public cette fois ci le biclou
ça change tout huis clos sa chance ça
change tout apparemment alors est ce
joueur n'était pas le seul yvelinois
présent dans cette quinzaine à roland
garros grégory a tout à fait y avait
aussi dans le tableau féminin chloé
paquet ce sens 85e joueuse mondiale et
formé à versailles à la perdu au premier
tour également 6 3 6 2 face à alizé
cornet que vous connaissez très bien qui
est 52e joueuse mondiale il y avait
également du côté du tour de tournoi des
juniors à roland garros antoine ghibaudo
il est né en janvier 2005 le 25 janvier
2005 il a quinze ans ça va pas rajeunir
certains il joue le roland garros
juniors cette année 1 pour la première
fois il a gagné au premier tour 6 4 3 6
6 3 contre l'indien j'avais acquis et en
plus plus âgé il a 18 ans j'avias mais
il a perdu malheureusement au deuxième
tour face au brésilien gustavo et qui
était tête de série numéro 14 ans se
tourne en deux sets 6 4 7 5
la question sur ce thème est ce que
c'est une vraie promesse pour le tennis
évinois ccp piz ela qui sortent cette
année oui non explicitées l'aiment et
pizzas et les nerfs que je donne la
parole yan dujarrier hélène c'est
peut-être un peu tôt pour le dire après
tout tout jeune sportif qui commença à
performer qui commence à accéder à des
championnats de cette ampleur là voilà
il faut les suivre de près la sont pas
voir des bonnes surprises on parle des
vraies révélations et des vraies stars
montantes mais c'est vrai qu'après il
est un peu tôt pour le dire yann c'est à
vous que je suis ce que je voulais dire
aussi bien pu vous parler de pépites
ils ont quand même perdu tous les deux
premiers tours et puis à l'heure pour la
petite pour la petite
ils sont qualifiés il ya perdu contre 1
800 touareg ailleurs ils font partie
quand même des meilleurs français même
s'ils se qualifient en étant compensées
et mais c'est la chance de faire partie
des boues france et fait que vous avez
accès
servanne garros mais là où je trouve
dommage c'est c'est la plus petite qui a
joué contre contre alizé cornet alizé
cornet elle est quand même coutumière de
perdre le premier tour au premier tour à
roland garros et donc elle a quand même
raté une belle occasion de pouvoir
passer au second tour
cette année elle avait décidé un petit
peu plus loin en tout cas bien chez
mclaren quand on prend beaucoup de
tirage au sort alizé cornet auprès du
tour on se dit et j'ai de gauche trop
sur ce que va dire je prends trop trop
tôt pour le dire c'est en plus la danse
et de la maintenant dans ces conditions
dans ces conditions du tournoi elle
résultera particulière je pense que la
préparation a été tronquée
le mental le mental aussi pour aborder
un événement comme celui là l'est tout
autant
donc je pense qu'il est un petit peu tôt
pour se prononcer laissons leur le temps
de décor et puis il y aura d'autres
d'autres premier tour contre alizé
cornet là je pense que ça passera les
fans de mise et il ya un bon vivier
quand même 1 2 et dans les yvelines de
tennisman
il ya environ 38 mille licenciés dans
les yvelines
il ya toujours des donc celle il ya un
bon millier vont êtres il ya toujours
des sportifs qui ressort de tout ça mais
après je crois qu'elle aussi elle était
invitée non vérifiés mais parce que
voilà donc ces voix là il faut voir ce
que ça donne dans l'avenir
pour l'instant c'est bien faut suivre 38
licenciés à grégory wimbée le tennis je
suis en train de bus lymphome et le
tennis ou et c'est le sport individuel
le plus pratiqué dans les yvelines donc
et après il ya une belle progression
on l'a vu pour arthur rinderknecht sur
ces derniers mois qui voit là et
maintenant dans une cent soixante
troisième place mondiale qui a gagné
deux tournois cette année donc pourquoi
pas à suivre
ça peut être encourageants et le petit
ghibaudo moi j'ai envie de voir ce que
ce que ça va donner
vous avez reçu deux personnes qui le
suivent régulièrement sur ce plateau le
président de la fédération française de
tennis dans le 7-8 sport est un
je quelqu'un qui est aussi un entraîneur
qui est le pôle de feucherolles tout à
fait qu'ils fondent de grands espoirs en
lui donc moi j'ai envie de voir ce que
ça donne ça serait possiblement le
prochain richard gasquet il ya un peu
plus grand pécheur gasquet mais ça
serait le prochain richard gasquet mais
attend de voir pierre chevalier qui type
qui peut on en est sûrs et qui peut
l'attester
pourquoi pas le prochain mon fils
pourquoi pourquoi pas le prochain noir
c'est finalement ces prochains mois
qu'on attend depuis depuis des années et
des années donc il ya je suis un petit
peu plus sensibles finalement à la
partie aux partis et aux parcours de
gaston parce que il a il a un vrai style
de jeu et qui semble qui semble
justement à contre-courant est assez
efficace contre les meilleurs il l'a
prouvé contre wawrinka
donc après que nos petits jeunes
puissent puisse éclore puissent
s'entraîner et puis se confronter au
plus haut niveau
maintenant à dire que ce sera le
prochain le prochain pour char moi je
dirais je dirais même pourvu que ce soit
pas le prochain gasquet parce que pour
vous pour ce retour vu que ce soit un un
futur champion qui dure et qui vous
ramène les titres se sont sans offense à
son palmarès
richard gasquet bien évidemment est-ce
que vous avez l'information
j'ai l'information a effectivement
bénéficié d'une wild card comme arthur
rhino darkness cette émission bon voila
j'ai pu vérifier et comme aussi un hugo
gaston qui a surpris tout le monde lors
de cette quinzaine à roland garros qui
n'est pas encore terminée mais lui aussi
a des nouvelles cartes donc avec une
webcam on peut aussi aller très longue
allée très loin
alors ce sera le mot de la fin sur cette
thématique on passe maintenant notre
page débats
dans cette page débat c'est votre
rubrique grégory nous l'avons baptisé
l'envolée de grégory de quoi allez vous
nous parler les gorilles bon je vais
peut-être cassé l'ambiance sur ce
plateau de bonne humeur et je vais
parler du coc vide 19 l'épidémie est
malheureusement encore présentes désolé
pour la tête mais voilà l'épidémie on et
voilà que pour elle est malheureusement
encore présente cette épidémie avec un
département des yvelines qui est classé
en zone alerte le sport doit continuer
mais ne doit pas être pour autant au
dessus de la vie des êtres humains doit
pas mettre en danger les vies humaines
alors ce paramètre du colis de 19 il a
été très bien a prise en compte par les
clubs sportifs amateurs comme
professionnels qui ont dû prendre en
compte donc ce paramètre pour cette
saison il a fallu s'adapter avec des
mesures sanitaires qui ont été mises en
place on en parle elle a des infos avec
pierre sur ce plateau notamment pour le
rugby mois pour le football il ya des
protocoles port du masque dans les
vestiaires dans toutes les parties
communes en dehors des terrains jusqu'à
la mise en place sur le terrain le
traçage des joueurs qui viennent
s'entraîner et qui joue des matches pour
identifier très rapidement s'il ya des
cas positifs au l'aller les cas qui ont
été en contact
le sport s'est adapté est ennuyeux mais
malheureusement le risque zéro n'existe
pas et on a vu un des cas de positivité
un peu partout dans le département
vous en avez parlé dans le 7-8 sports
michael des suspicions de kobe de 19 ont
été décelés au rugby-club de plaisir à
la fin de l'été résultat les joueurs
n'ont pas pu s'entraîner durant une
semaine et c'est une semaine décisive
puisque c'est celle qui précédait la
première journée de championnat de
fédérale 2 ils n'ont pas pu s'entraîner
les plaisirs où aller ils ont perdu ce
match face à poidevin 25 à 24
je vais un peu d'un point ça s'est joué
d'un temps donc on peut penser qu'avec
une forme physique un peu plus fraîches
il aurait pu aller chercher cette
victoire ils ont perdu aussi leur
deuxième journée de championnat et ils
ont gagné lors de la 3e journée
je ne dis pas qu'il faut aller chercher
voilà ce paramètre covit comme la seule
justification à ses deux défaites pour
débuter mais je pense que ça forcément
influé depuis le début de saison aussi
le sport yvelinois dû faire face à
plusieurs reports c'est le cas pour
l'ess poissy le
ap de football a compté au même moment
neuf cas positifs dans son effectif et
la rencontre face à châteaubriant elle
n'avait pas pu se tenir c'est lé 19
septembre dernier elle se tiendra
finalement en ce mercredi 7 octobre
et on sait nationale 2 c'est de la
nationale 2 pour le football donc c'est
le quatrième niveau national on sait que
pour avoir le rythme fois ci on sait
aussi qu'ils sont en mauvaise passe dans
cette nationale 2 ils sont bons derniers
pour accumuler le rythme des matches il
faut n'a pas dû les aider ça peut être
les aider il faut les enchaîner donc on
peut aussi estimer voilà qui n'ont pas
eu toutes les ressources nécessaires
alors il ya aussi d'autres sports le
handball pour terminer les féminines de
montigny le bretonneux qui évolue en
nationale 2 ont été concernés par le
coronavirus côté masculin ce sont les
handballeurs de plaisir qui se sont
retrouvés aussi privé de match en raison
du coronavirus alors malheureusement ce
n'est que le début on est à un mois
seulement du début de la saison ça fait
un mois qu'on a repris qu'on a repris
cette saison il y aura forcément
d'autres épisodes à venir avec des
préparations physique tronquée des
calendriers qui va falloir sans cesse
remodelé et des dates de report qui vont
être de plus en plus difficiles à
trouver des joueurs clés aussi qu'ils
vont peut-être manqué à des moments clés
de la saison certaines rencontres pour
moi l'épidémie elle va fausser
complètement cette saison sportive
c'est peut-être pessimiste mais pour moi
le grand vainqueur de cette saison avec
le commis de 19 non vous pouvez pas dire
ça gregorio les moules vainqueur seco
vide tout et tout est faussé
entraînements les matchs convient de
regagner enfin là dessus on peut rien
dire
vous faites durant le fauteuil notamment
être impactés de votre côté mais les
conditions c'est qu'on doit arriver au
gymnase avec le masque on l'enlève pour
les entraînements et ensuite on leur met
pour quitter le pour quitter le gymnase
mais c'est sûr qu'on s'entraîne pas dans
des conditions normales et des joueurs
qui peuvent pas venir parce qu'ils sont
fragiles
il y en a d'autres qui sont importants
pour l'équipe qui viennent pas parce
qu'ils ont peur
donc tout est poussé tout est faux c'est
hélène à ce que vous avez ce sentiment
là aussi tout est faussé
pâques c'est le grand vainqueur en tout
cas ces gros adversaire
c'est moi s'appelle serge gainsbourg que
ce soit dans la pratique dans la
compétition dans les entraînements
il ya ça met des bâtons dans les roues
ça ça change toute l'organisation
structurelle de chaque activité toute
l'organisation
comment dire au niveau des plannings et
des habitudes d adhérence et tout est
remis à zéro
non je dirais pas ça mais tout et voilà
tout tout tout est entachée et tout est
entravée il ya vraiment on est pas du
tout on pourra jamais qu'on parlait ces
années-là des années sens encore de lire
aussi bien dujarrier vous qui êtes très
en colère quand on parle de coronavirus
de kobe 19
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce qu
il a gagné ceux commis 19 ben non il est
emmené en guerre avec lui et c'est nous
qui avons gagné alors là non plus on y
va il va nous embêter il va nous
déranger pendant longtemps
oui ça c'est clair mais de toute façon
c'est nous qui allons gagner
qu allons gagner au final on va trouver
on va trouver comment le comment le
comment l'année entière tout simplement
non aujourd'hui oui voilà il faut il
faut donc s'adapter il faut modifier sa
façon de sa façon de vivre
et puis pour ce que ça fait de jarrier
vous savez je vais comparer ça où on dit
toujours sur 1 sur 1 sur un plat de
ligue 1 chaque équipe a toujours des
penalties refusés ou et c est bien là
c'est un peu le même principe c'est à
dire que oui peut y voir des équipes qui
vont à certains moments vont êtres vont
être favorisée à d'autres moments sont
défavorisés je pense que tout le monde
va être un peu monde est impacté par
deux de la même manière parce par ce
virus donc
vivons avec vivons avec et avançons et
puis c'est tout quoi on va on va on
gagnera le match on gagnera le match
contre caen 3-1 contre la coved et puis
et puis maintenant
maintenant prenons les mesures mais
quand tu veux vivre
pierre chevalier restaurant au niveau du
sport départemental et dans les yvelines
est un exemple que je connais bien
grégory l'a rappelé il assure la partie
rugby je pense que c'est avec les
matches reportés que va commencer
vraiment le joli bazar et l'inéquité
sportive
on a actuellement on a déjà connu dans
le championnat de fédérale 3 par exemple
avec le rc versailles qui par ailleurs a
bien commencé pour nous mais on a on a
connu déjà des reports de matchs dès la
première journée
sur les six matches de sur les six
matches de la poule il y avait déjà
trois matches trois matches reportés
sont reportés actuellement en février il
y en a eu sur la 3e journée et il y en a
il y en aura sans doute sur la quatrième
qui se joue dimanche
il ya un moment il ya un moment où le
calendrier ne pourra plus absorber
justement tout c'est tous ces reports là
et il va y avoir un choix à faire en
terme d'équité sportive et en terme de
règles monde on vous a perdu à pierre
chevalier
est-ce qu'on vous récupère ses lacets là
où le voilà vous entends c'est c'est là
où le c'est là où le où le virus aura
joué son rôle de perturbateur est
effectivement de grands de grand
chamboulement des saisons sportives
parce que justement il n'y aura pas de
place pour tout le monde il ya un moment
ou un autre il faudra vous a encore
perdu un chevalier diane si vous voulez
rajouter peut-être quelque chose sur ce
que vient de dire à pierre chevalier
il ya nigeria à la fin du bal qu'on paye
les compères
stéphane de l'isère oui c'est sûr
qu'avec tous les matchs reportés ça va
être un gros embouteillage à la fin de
la saison va falloir les places et
peut-être je sais pas annulée si ça se
fait c'est sûr que le colis devraient
bien foutu le bordel
en tout cas vous avez vous avez l'air
d'avoir un petit peu chamboulé tout le
monde un chanceux il a demandé juste
pour on a perdu la connexion soit avec
certains mais c'est vrai que c'était un
peu provocateur j'ai dit grand vainqueur
il ya bien sûr dans le sport des
vainqueurs des fois qu'on n'aime pas et
ce vainqueur que les 19 jeux ne l'aiment
pas mais malheureusement il va s'imposer
pour moi cet été votre envolé à grégory
vous en aurez une autre la prochaine
fois alors continue ceux ci ont parlé
sport par deux la boxe après un an sans
être remonté sur le ring tony yoka le
boxeur de 28 ans originaires de
chanteloup les vignes s'est facilement
imposé contre johann duhoo passe à paris
le champion olympiques 2016 a dominé son
adversaire un peu plus d'une minute dès
la première reprise libinois toujours
invaincus en huit combats dont 7 avant
la limite il vise dans les prochaines
années un titre mondial
la question sur ce thème tony yoka est
il prêt pour aller chercher ce titre
mondial oui oui pour vous ce afin de
viser nouioui pardon oui parce que j'ai
vu le combat
je cherche pas dire son nom à
l'adversaire la lloba studio pass duo
passerait il a réussi à lui mettre est
la limite une petite droite dans les
quatre cinq premières secondes
mais après il a subi un bulldozer
tractopelle
tout ce que vous voulez la paix puis il
a pu vous le jour et je sais pas c'est à
la fin qu'on le voit tomber quand il
prend son le coup fatal
il est en train de se dire mais qu'est
ce qui se passe et ce qui s'est préparée
sérieusement c'est ça la question en
fait où est ce qu il a sous-estimé tony
yoka traits qu'on en parlait beaucoup de
ce match et notamment par voilà des
déclarations interposées il ya eu
beaucoup d'échangés vifs entre les deux
avant le match tony hawk eye qui disait
que duo passe les vitesses depuis
plusieurs mois parce qu'il peut préférer
boxer à l'étranger contre des dires des
plus grosses têtes d'affiché et perdre
mais voilà qu'en tout cas il voulait
éviter tony yoka duo passe alors c'est
peut-être peut-être énervé ça va
peut-être énervé et pour aller dans le
sens de stéphane grosse prestation de
tony hawk à puisque voilà duo passe
avait pas mal embêter duty ou haider qui
est l'un des gros sur la scène mondiale
il avait pas mal embêter lors d'un match
et déjanté où elle wyler avait dit oui
que c'était l'un des boxeurs les plus
difficiles qu'il avait eu à affronter du
occasion que ça ajoute du crédit à cette
performance de tony hawk à en 87
secondes
voyez des riders 1 42 victoires pour 41
k o
depuis début de sa carrière une défaite
et un nul et il a 34 ans et une tête
d'affiché vraiment de la discipline
alors s y est collé c'est un honneur
est ce qu'il est prêt ou pas pierre
chevallier seront je pense qu'il est je
pense qu'il est de plus en plus près
donc là je ferai juste un parallèle
comme on parle de sport dans cette
émission avec sport et spectacle on en a
on a en ce moment pas pas l'occasion de
voir beaucoup de beaucoup de rencontres
sportives ont 2 - dans des conditions
normales liu arena de la défense c'était
le cas les spectateurs on en tête eu
honte et tu justement des regrets donc
que ça ne dure pas plus longtemps mais
faut pas le faux se rappeler que
l'objectif quand même et la stratégie
diot cas c'était c'était de ne pas
l'emmener loin dans les routes parce que
justement c'est un c'est un besogneux et
qui qui emmène ses combattants vraiment
loin dans ce combat est qui qui peut
gagner aux points plus tôt par char
carreau donc là il a appliqué sa
stratégie ça va marcher c'est assez
spectaculaire
effectivement totalement inattendue et
c'est ce qui nous ce qui me fait penser
ce qui me fait dire que que qu'il était
dans des conditions particulières ils
étaient près donc contre une contre une
contre un docteur de cette trempe-là
champions de ce tremplin le mettre au
tapis en 87 secondes ça c'est juste
c'est juste assez assez phénoménal donc
donc vraiment ou plutôt plus tôt la
partie oui il est prêt et vivement que
ça arrive c'est plutôt positif pour vous
grégory canal il faut pas oublier que ça
faisait un an qu'il n'avait pas mis les
gants tony yoka à cause du coronavirus
yade est forcément des rencontres qui
ont pas pu se tenir mais aussi parce que
il ya eu ces suspicions de dopage trois
manquements à des des contrôles
antidopages donc c'est une belle
revanche voilà deux depuis
c'est fait et c'est vrai que tony yoka
c'était dans sa stratégie il a dit après
le combat c'était de tester son
adversaire et il a senti très vite qu'il
y avait une opportunité je suis c'est un
combat qui était prévu en douze rounds
donc grosse grosse performance fait de
l'évoquer il a signé également avec un
nouveau promoteur américain
tout à fait il devrait faire des combats
baby girl je crois qu'hier tout à fait
jaser nom qui est énorme c'est quelque
part voilà et il faudra normalement des
combats aux états unis et ce qu'il faut
quand même qu'ils attendent un petit peu
hélène selon vous avant de se lancer
dans un championnat du monde contre 1
anthony joshua hunt et why there un
tyson fury des comptes boxeur je pense
que lui-même se pose pas ce genre de
question il ya un peu en fonction de ce
qu'on lui propose
il avait aussi la l'énergie de galets
autant qu'il y aille
après après de toute façon comme on
disait une année sans combat c on aura
des réponses assez rapidement dans les
prochains combats et et puis des combats
qu'ils auront qu'il aura aux etats-unis
aussi vont vont quand même pas mal joué
et c'était son souhait aussi il me
semble qu'on avait un peu parlé de ça de
près il veut faire qu'est-ce que petit
combat entre guillemets pour être prêt
pour des gros combat
elles sont toutes experts c'est bon à
prendre donc autant qu'ils le fassent
après c'est aussi à lui de juger
voilà si tu sens prêt à y aller si la
s'il estime avoir assez d'expérience
assez d'entraînement les chances qu'un
moment donné entre les opportunités sont
là il faut y aller donner le meilleur et
ouais il faut y aller il ya dujarrier
week est un fan absolu de boxe cana
solide box donc oui moi j'avais j'avais
quand même suivi la préparation et j'ai
fait quelques spécialistes justement
avant le avant le match comme j'ai vu le
résultat du match
je peux dire juste que ce que les
spécialistes disaient avant le match
c'est à dire que si tony yoka de gagner
ce match avec la manière et je pense
qu'un cas où 87 secondes basse et avec
la manière
il prenait une place dans la hiérarchie
mondiale
chose qu'ils n'avaient pas encore fait
jusqu'à jusqu'à présent puisqu'on
pouvait critiquer les adversaires qu'ils
avaient plus qu il avait pu avoir et
donc les spécialistes l'attendaient sur
ce sur ce match pensez vraiment que ce
serait un match qu'ils iraient à la fin
des deux rondes et que vraiment ils
local n'était peut-être même pas le
favori du du match au départ donc
donc voilà web pour moi il a il a marqué
les esprits
[Musique]
il est prêt alors peut-être pas aller
chercher un jeu choix parce que bon même
si on sait qu'ils ont à peu près vers
agen je crois qu'ils ont deux trois ans
d'écart il n'y a pas une brosse il n'y a
pas une grosse différence mais mais
voilà je pense que maintenant il ne
reste plus qu'aux grandes marches à
gravir pour pouvoir prétendre à aller
allez allez combattre pour aller glaner
ce titre ce titre mondial et et moi je
dis juste chapeau parce que les jeux
olympiques cd ya quatre ans c'était à 4
ans qui naquit qu'il est arrivé au
devant de la scène
grâce aux grâce aux jo en l'espace de
quatre ans et dont un an de suspension
et non pas pour suspicion de dopage mais
pour un show c'est tout la même chose
grégory et il faut pas la manquer
l'épreuve
il a manqué des contrôles antidopage et
mais c'est pas des suspicions de dopage
manqué des contrôles antidopages ces
voix là je ne suis pas présenté donc je
suis sanctionné et la sanction c'était
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il a été
qu'il était donc il faut savoir que les
conditions pour respecter les nouveaux
sont justes enfin pour respecter les
contrôles sont vraiment vraiment très
compliqué pour les sportifs au quotidien
à vivre au quotidien donc et on a des
sportifs très proches à qui c'est déjà
arrivé donc et pourtant on n'a jamais
dit qu'ils étaient dopés qu'il a été
pénalisé un an son combat est arrivé à
ce niveau là en moins de quatre ans et
ben vraiment chapeau et moi je lui
souhaite de pouvoir aller à l'état qui
les a pas qu'il allait le battre et
combattre face à des aléas les
adversaires qui méritent de pouvoir
rencontrer puisque maintenant il a il a
plu passe voilà on va passer la
prochaine thématique on vous a vu en
elle elle aussi avec votre chien en
train de vous battre à vous de votre
côté un confort mais également pour
peut-être combattre tony au cap
alors on continue ce départ du football
on our une page paris à saint germain le
club installé sur notre territoire à
saint germain en laye et qui déménagera
bientôt sur la commune de poissy ce qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est le
mercato le psg s'est renforcé cet été
avec plusieurs joueurs des joueurs pas
forcément connus du grand public mais
des bons joueurs des grues des bons
joueurs alors on peut dire que le psg on
a rendu un peu plus riches un effectif
un peu plus riches même si on pourra en
discuter
l'effectif est peut-être un peu moins
compétitifs en tout cas il ya plusieurs
joueurs qui sont allés chercher en prêt
alors c'est un mercato un peu
particulier dans un contexte où les
clubs ont perdu beaucoup d'argent a
notamment des recettes de billetterie
qui n'ont pas pu rentrer donc pour faire
du mercato cette année les clubs plutôt
que de vendre les joueurs ont eu recours
à des formules de prêt de prêt avec
option d'achat
voilà pour reporter aussi ses ventes au
saison prochaine alors il ya florensis
lorenzi latéral droit italien il en
provenance de l'as roma où il avait plu
temps de jeu à l'as roma l'année
dernière d'ailleurs il avait été prêté
du côté de valence où il était parti
titulaire et finale au final il a perdu
sa place de titulaire à un autre italien
c'est moïse qui noyaient skins qui a été
formé à la juve belles promesses du
football italien
mais qui s'est perdu un petit peu la
saison dernière à everton où ils étaient
vendus et où il n'a marqué que deux buts
la saison dernière
même avec ancelotti 1 sur le banc depuis
la moitié de la saison dernière il n'a
pas gagné de galons de titulaire mois
estime donc il arrive aussi à paris avec
un statut de deux paris lui ce n'est pas
vraiment à paris c'est danilo pereira
capitaine du fc porto qui arrivent
également en prêt mais avec une option
d'achat
danilo pereira qui à 29 ans
international portugais qui a un profil
très intéressant qui pourra épauler au
mieux de terrain marco garatti donc lui
c'est vraiment une référence à son poste
et la petite surprise en fin de mercato
seraphina qu'on n'attendait pas
forcément dire personne qui vient de
barcelone qui était plus titulaire à
barcelone mais qui amène obtient de ce
mari également à paris un peu plus de
solution avec un profil de milieu
relayeur aux militaires mais dans le
même temps paris a perdu thiago silva
edison cavani et thomas meunier est ce
que le psg s'est finalement renforcé en
vue de cette ligue des champions qui
n'ont pas réussi à avoir cette année en
perdre en finale contre le bayern de
munich
c'est la question sur cette thématique
stéphane de bizet je vous donne la
parole et on profère petit tour de table
est ce que le pgc plus fort ou pas que
la saison dernière pour apporter cette
ligue des champions tous les ans et 10 1
mais après
comment dire moi ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'ils manquent un taulier à
chaque à chaque poste
pour moi il faut un taulier en défense
il faut un taulier en milieu de terrain
et pour que les attaquants puis jouer
entre eux et arrêter de faire du neymar
mba pmb neymar ça joue pas ensemble en
attaque et tant qu'ils y arriveront pas
ils pourront pas gagner cette ligue des
champions même s'ils se renforce tous
les ans avec des superstars mais bon y'a
nigérienne dubitatif maintenant parce
que ben on y perd on perd un cavani qui
qui qui 200 plus de 100 buts pour paris
meilleur buteur 10 ans du label comment
le meilleur buteur de l'histoire du club
j'ai d'ailleurs un meilleur buteur de
l'histoire du club
je sais pas ce que ce que c'est voir
qu'ils étaient en perdition dans l'eure
dans leurs clubs respectifs vont pouvoir
apporter au psg j'espère que ils ont vu
en eux d'aider pepy et que tomasz toral
pourra réussir à en sortir le meilleur
le meilleur en banque
voilà ce que l'on peu ce que l'on peut
souhaiter la seule chose que moi je peux
dire aujourd'hui c'est que ben la
réponse on la verra dans quelques jours
lors du premier match psg manchester
on sait que déjà à paris a comme avait
eu du mal à rentrer dans son championnat
de france même si c'était pas très très
mal parce que là la finalité on l'a on
l'a connu au niveau du championnat
secours non ben la ligue des champions
ses filles match qu'il ne faut pas rater
pour pouvoir très rapidement s'est
qualifiée pour les tours pour les tours
suivants donc hélas il faut ils font
rentrer dedans tout de suite et on
attaque par un gros morceau qui l'on
espère même si manchester revient de
prendre à un gros carton à domicile le
week-end dernier
plus manchester cavaliers chevalier très
rapidement et hélène aussi très
rapidement c'est bientôt chose que
l'émission moi je pense que c'est
surtout ce très sobre et très est très
cohérent dire que c'est beaucoup moins
clinquant que les premières années
qatari il ya beaucoup moins de il ya
beaucoup moins d'euros il ya beaucoup
moins de grandes stars sauf que c'est
laid c'est sûrement des seconds couteaux
assez efficace et un peu revanchard
notamment rafinha qui est de retour de
prêt du celta vigo ça à mon avis c'est
la bonne pioche donc plutôt cohérent
sabri mois hélas non tout pareil
maintenant j'ai pas grand chose est très
très rapidement pour dire aussi qu'il ya
aussi une cardy et sérgio rico qui sont
aussi dans ce mercato parisien qui était
déjà prêté la saison dernière au paris
saint germain le paris saint-germain les
acheter et juste pour rajouter galouzeau
voilà je pense qu'ils ont un effectif
plus riche mais en attaque ça s'est
affaiblie ils ont perdu cabanis ont
perdu choupo moting aussi qui est un bon
remplaçant et moïse skin ça reste un
pari on va voir s'ils arrivent à
s'imposer au paris saint germain
suivrait avec attention en tout cas dans
ceux ci ont parlé sport c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission on va terminer
comme d'habitude par une citation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
du tennisman rodger federer certains
veulent kg est arrivé
certains espèrent y arriver d'autres y
arrivent
je vous laisse méditer sur très
rapidement c'est la fin des missions et
aux stéphanois visiblement de fauteuils
ce week-end à montigny samedi si vous
voulez venir boire allez-y les endiablé
vous encore gagné on va voir ça à
bientôt sur tv 78